hi guys congratulations hi
hi olivia i wanted to start with you
here because i know
you have a significant amount of tv
experience
in particular home in a way but even
having worked on so many episodes over
there
what was it about being on a big film
set like this that kind of
still surprised you about the process
well i think it was just
two completely different scenarios as
well like um
in australia as you said it's a lot it's
a lot of a smaller community
um so and you know you do all like i
had never when i got told i had a stunt
double i was like what
or when i got told that we had stand-ins
and catering
and that i could take a five-minute
break it was like a holiday
uh like i remember when someone like
that they said okay you can walk on
offset and have a stand and i was like
no
i would get in so much trouble if i did
that in australia
um so there were two completely
different experiences for me um
i think what i took away from home and
away with the crazy hours i was used to
working 15 hour
15 hour days like you know 60 to 70 hour
weeks and having to learn pages and
pages of lines
so i came in with that mentality um and
especially because
i was in toronto i was in a new country
jet lag and i was on a different
contract so i could work
longer hours um so i was equipped but
there were you know hugely different
experiences and very different genres
like home and away is a reality drama
whereas
you know this is a cgi film and the
makeup and costumes
it was incredible but two very different
experiences that i'm lucky that i've had
i can imagine folly i can't not ask you
about this being such a big
mcgarress fan what was it like working
on nightmare cinema
and what did you take from your
experience working with him over there
to a movie like this
that was the last question i was
expecting to hear today
wow um nightmare cinema was a blessing
that was one of
the first lead roles i'd ever i think it
was the first
actually um especially in a film with
a horror legend like mick garris you
know working on nightmare cinema
it was amazing because it really um it
introduced me to a world of
special effects you know but more more
horror themes special effects obviously
you know there's a
there's a lot of you know fake blood and
stuff going on which was really cool but
i think it helped me prepare for this
role in the sense of like i get to
pretend to be in another reality
like i get a nightmare cinema so it's
just uh another sense of just being
in different realities so yeah it
definitely prepared me for
this for sure i love the neighborhood
cinema every second of that
so one of my favorite parts of this
movie is the incredible ensemble it's so
easy to fall in love with all you guys
so a couple rapid fire questions tell me
who answers the question and then maybe
why who of the ensemble is most like
their character
isabella like thomas for sure
she's like like spitting it's just like
a it's just like
it's just like isabella in high-end
fashion essentially
i'd say spitting image yeah
if you guys could swap roles with anyone
in the film who would you pick and why
i love mike as a character who we
haven't really been introduced to yet
but i want teleportation as a power
so i i just want to play everyone they
go i just wanna i'm sleepless i just
wanna do everything
yeah i'd probably switch man i probably
switched with tuma i liked his um
i liked his extremely confident and
boastful personality as a character and
i feel like
that would be a fun character for to
portray someday so yeah
right now i'm assuming you guys have
been asked a million times what power
you would want so i'm gonna steal a
question i used from a different junket
if you could have like the most boring
but practical super superpower out there
what would you choose and why
that's a really good question
impractical
i think organize i'm so i'm just such a
massive procrastinator
and like i'm so bad at organizing things
that i think just like
being organized and actually completing
tasks in an
in an appropriate time setting which is
just something
people should have which i just don't so
that'd be cool
that's pretty easy sometimes i get it
yeah
well we have it for you i have to say
like a clean freak probably
everywhere i go everything just cleans
around me like on its own
because i'm a pretty i make some messes
sometimes so i feel like if i walk
around everything just
you know like in cinderella like a
little and like the the
the all the accessories would start
walking and they'd start sweeping and
they do everything on their own
like everywhere it's like all laughing
with this little like snowflake
halo it's like you're in your own little
clean bubble yeah yeah it would just
happen you should be like
very into that idea but i have a feeling
that like mine would have to be if i
could snack my fingers and create
good wi-fi everywhere i go i'd be a real
happy person
why didn't i think of that
no all right i want to make mine like i
have a soundtrack for everywhere i am
i want to just pretend i'm in movies so
i'd be like this is an appropriate song
and i just hear it like i'm in my own
little soundtrack
everywhere you go it's just like
blasting just yeah just everyone's like
what's that noise and i'm there like
yeah this is appropriate
i love it thank you guys so much for
your time today and again huge congrats
on the movie
it is a blast thank you